the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences presents its 35th annual
achievement awards these people like
most of us are movie fans from all over
the country they've come to the Civic
Auditorium here in Santa Monica
California for a glimpse of their
favorite actors as the most famous faces
in the world arrived to attend Oscars
annual coming-out party
he suspense has begun to mount as some
of Hollywood's most glamorous
last-minute elite rushed into the
theater in time for the overture their
Jack Lord of stony birth
Eva Marie sink
there's a little patty do
as Lee Remick with Austin bilko
there's Bob stack the missus they
established our in pictures before his
success in the untouchable
and Gregory Peck nominee this year for
his work as Atticus Finch in To Kill a
Mockingbird
miss Sophia Loren an Academy Award
winner last year or two women
there's Ginger Rogers
Danny Thomas one of the best-loved band
in the entertainment world
there's Joan Crawford one of the
Immortals of filmdom and Edward G
Robinson all bearded
ladies and gentlemen your host for this
evening Frank Sinatra
a funny thing happened to me last time I
was in Washington which Cincinnati was
quite a while ago I was passing the
National Gallery I guess you might call
it an art house and all the way around
the block was a tremendous line of
people waiting to get in to see a little
Italian picture called a Mona Lisa my
first reaction was go fight it these
Italian picture makers of a knocking our
brains out for years my second reaction
was I wanted how come the three
centuries later they were still lining
up to see a picture not widescreen
doesn't even move a talk the chick just
sits there and smiles well not even
smile she kind of smiles how come
they're still lining up to see it I'm
still not sure but maybe maybe it's
because the Mona Lisa represents one
man's personal vision a picture he had
to make not something turned out on an
assembly line because the Italian
painting industry needed product but a
picture he had to make so badly his
brushes hurt actually a marvellous thing
is beginning to happen to us here other
mediums have come along that can turn
out assembly line product English
translation junk faster and cheaper and
better than we can and whether we like
it or not that we want to compete we're
being forced back into the mona lisa
business ourselves and we're beginning
to find out it's a pretty nice business
to be in only a couple of years ago say
if Leonardo da Vinci had wanted to make
the Mona Lisa out here he might have had
a few problems here and there for
instance the scene of producers office
DaVinci enters and explains he's got an
idea for a picture a beautiful woman he
starts sitting there smiling
well not exactly smiling kind of smile
he finished his a nothing there's a long
silence finally the producer speaks well
he says I don't know but it does have a
great part for a girl now if we can get
somebody to pose for it Liz maybe or
Ingrid doris or even aunt Margaret some
kind of a name like that you know
Leonardo baby I like it I really like it
and we might even change the title to
Mona Anna Lisa pick up some of the odd
house crowd that way see the Vincey
goats but he got a house in Brentwood
three kids and an analyst to support
argue about it now the producers really
getting warmed up you've got a picture
here he says we really got a picture now
all you gotta do Leonardo baby it's just
paint a guy in there looking over her
shoulder see we get rock or Greg but
Tony is somebody to post for just for a
love interest and the motivation we got
to clean that up I mean you just can't
have a daemon sitting there smiling you
gotta tell the audience what's he
smiling about
Leonardo sweetheart if I were making
this picture which I am I'd paint in
some big kind of a cocktail party scene
in the foreground
give it some production value it's a
flashback see she's smiling and thinking
about the decadent life she used to
leave before she I don't know joined the
Peace Corps so anyway that's how they
made Mona and Lisa for eight million
dollars open it at the Music Hall where
it bombed out for obvious reasons and
six months later they're sold at the
television now obviously this little
story is not true nothing like that
could happen here the truth the happy
tooth is that many of the pictures and
artists were honoring here tonight are
already in the Mona Lisa business making
pictures because they as artists want to
make them because they have to make them
so badly their cameras and their
typewriters and their eyebrow pencils
hurt and as I said it's a pretty nice
business to be in and now that I've got
this message of my massive chest let us
make the evening official ladies and
gentlemen the president of the Motion
Picture Academy of Arts and Sciences mr.
Wendell cook
good evening the Academy's board of
governors proudly welcomes you all to
our 35th annual awards we are proud of
the pictures we will honor this evening
and of the people will announce these
honors every presentation will be made
by a former hospital winner tonight most
of them are here in the auditorium some
you will see on film from Europe as
always the announcement we make here
create headlines everywhere for this
advantage is the culmination of a year's
work as with all the hearts of millions
those of us who were paid to make these
films those of you who god bless you pay
to see them now happily for us most more
of you have been beguiled by the
imagination vigor and artistry of these
for this year's films and ever before
now let's see if you agree with the more
than 2,500 members of the Academy who
have owned by secret ballot the
accounting house server Price Waterhouse
haven't any of these balanced the final
results were compiled by one gentleman
who at this moment is approaching with
the information that he and he alone
knows mr. bill
paradise is tabulated the official
ballots results when they see a llama I
could go in a few moments the former
Oscar winner will turn to mr. Miller and
say the envelope please so don't go too
far bill do we deduce that Oscar winner
here again is our master of ceremonies
the distinguished art critic mr. Frank
Sinatra
a recent lecturer in the cloister pause
of Harvard University's young lady who
won her letter on the sound stages of
Hollywood in the great academic
tradition of Emerson and law the oscar
winner for her performance in the Diary
of Anne Frank miss Shelley Winters
there goes the bus that means thank you
I think in Latin I'll check with my
druggist I'll be right up
tonight students of the cinema are all
you people out there who pay to go to
the movies we will start with two
categories the first is best achievement
in sound now a famous director mr.
George Stevens once explained to me that
movies were mostly visual and sound in
television was mostly audio due to the
size of the viewing screen but nowadays
when you make a movie you're not sure if
or when it's going to end up on
television so you see a sound man has
not only to be a artists and craftsmen
but he has to be something of a prophet
as well so in our category of sound and
prophets we have five nominees they are
Walt Disney Studios sound Department for
bon voyage Shepherd and studio sound
Department for Lawrence of Arabia Warner
Brothers Studios sound Department
remarried as Wilson's the sound of music
or The Music Man
Universal City Studios sound apartment
for that touch of mink and Glen Glen
sound Department for whatever happened
to Baby Jane the envelope please mr.
numbers the winner in a shepherd in
studio department for Lawrence of Arabia
Robert Wagner
mr. Bob Wagner accepting on behalf of
John [ __ ] Columbia Pictures my friends
David Lane and Sam Spiegel I'm very
proud and very pleased to accept this
award
the best way to define special effects
which is our category number two is
sending the pictures that cost the most
money first the longest a visual effects
by Robert McDonald and audible effects
by Chuck mama the second nominee is
mutiny on the bounty visual effect by
Arnold Gillespie audible effects by
Marlo Laurie the winners are Robert
McDonald and Jacque mama for the longest
day
excepting for Robert McDonald and
Jacques Momo Ivan Martin
this is very hard for an actress to let
go of behalf of mr. Robert Donnell and
mr. moment my thanks and appreciation is
it